And now it's the old scout master.
We had a great backpacking trip this weekend with the troop-
Great weather.
We were up on the Appalachian Trail in Pennsylvania.
We did our nine miles of that 2000 mile plus trail that stretches all the way from Maine
to Georgia
And in that stretch Pennsylvania has the dubious distinction of being the rockiest
part of the Appalachian Trail
And I think, after this weekend, also the one that probably people use
more ibuprofen per mile.
We had a great time anyway.
Hey, this is podcast number 146..
Welcome back to the Scout Master podcast.
This is Clark Green.
Let's take a look in the mailbag.
Let's see who we've heard from here.
Jason Reedy got in touch with us about podcast number 145, our last podcast.
We had a Scout Master panel discussion about starting a new troop
And Jason had this to say: what a great podcast.
We just started our troop in September.
It's been an interesting road so far.
It's not easy at any stretch, but it's well worth it.
No, the Norman Rockwell version does not exist.
Those boys do not actually exist, but the real boys are much more fun
And they are all incredible.
We started with 10 and we are now up to 14 in just two months.
I was lucky and got signed up for Wood Badge earlier this year and centered my ticket
around creating a successful troop.
That has been a great help.
Good luck and be prepared for many lessons-
Some to be taught and some to be learned
Well. thank you for being in touch, Jason.
I'm glad to hear that you're having a successful first few months with the troop.
It's a challenge, isn't it,
But that's why we're doing the work.
We love a good challenge.
I got this message too.
He says: hi, Clark.
I wanted to simply thank you for all that I've learned from your podcasts and the
reaffirmations of previous experiences and lessons from my own travels as a Scout.
Your podcast is a highlight of my travels.
I primarily drive all day for my job and I truly look forward to them as they are released.
I have encouraged other leaders in Cub Scouts as well as in Boy Scouts to listen for a better
understanding of the meaning and purposes behind Scouting.
I do not get a lot of time to sit at a computer and peruse the web, so I have just recently
started to follow the blog by email.
I see I've been missing another great resource and some of it may be better understood
than just the podcast alone,
At least judging from some of the looks I've received when I mentioned the podcast to other
people.
Yeah, there's this guy and he, like, has this thing and it's called a podcast and he talks
about Scouts.
Yeah, you can get a couple funny looks that way.
Please keep up the excellent resource and the great community that you have.
It's a guiding light to steer by, and, being one that prefers avoiding attention, I will
simply say thank you from California.
Well, thank you, California.
I hope you're driving goes well and I'm so glad you're listening and you're finding
things helpful.
You know, if you go to scoutmastercgcom, you can subscribe to all the updates to the
blog by email.
You can do that and I'll repeat that towards the end of the podcast.
Jeff is Scoutmaster of Troop 965 in Kuwait City, Kuwait,
And he wrote in to say this: Clark, I'm perhaps your farthest regular podcast
listener on the planet.
Perhaps
I think we'll give you that distinction, Jeff, until somebody tells me differently,
As I'm a Scoutmaster in Kuwait with BSA Troop 965, I download your podcast and
listen to them on my commute to work in Kuwait City.
I started at the beginning and just finished with number 27,- your summer
music special.
What a kick.
Wow, that's always back, but I'm glad you're listening, Jeff.
My son and I are relatively new to scouting, as we joined less than two years
ago,
In January 2012,. I became a Scoutmaster because our troop couldn't
recharge her without one.
Since I could fog a mirror, I was unanimously elected by our small but
dedicated troop committee.
Since then, it's been a wild ride and a great learning experience.
I had wanted to go to Wood badge last summer when we were back in the states,
but family needs prevented me from doing so.
I know that you would demur from me saying so, but your podcasts have
been my substitute Wood badge.
Don't worry, I still plan to go to Wood badge someday, maybe next summer,
But until then, I'm learning a lot from you and the other experienced
Scouters who comment on your site.
Take care and keep up the great work.
And that's Jeff in Kuwait City.
Thank you, Jeff.
Thanks for being in touch and thanks for listening over there in Kuwait.
I'm happy you're finding these useful and you're enjoying the podcast.
I have this audio addition to the mailbag. this week,
Shane Stillwell was part of a Google Plus Hangout, which is a deal where you can
get together with other people online and have a live discussion,
And that was hosted by Arlen Ward on Google Plus a couple of weeks ago,
And we even made it the subject of a Scoutmaster panel discussion
in the last podcast.
But Shane shared a story on the Google Plus Hangout that I thought
would interest you and I asked him if he would record it, and he did,
And here it is.
Hi, this is Shane Stillwell, Scoutmaster for Troop 168 in Cloquet, Minnesota.
I have a small story to tell you.
It began with our first camp out ever as a new troop.
We started back in January of this year
And in February we went on our first camp out in the snow
And the Scouts decided that they wanted to have pancake. Saturday morning-
And a new troop we have pretty limited on equipment
And they didn't have a spatula to cook with or flip the pancakes.
They started mixing the batter and, sure enough, they even put the pancake batter
on the griddle and it dawned on them
They had nothing to flip those pancakes with.
So me being the the ultra prepared gear nut fanatic that I am,
I of course had a flip out spatula back in my packet near my tent
And I thought, well, it's time for Scoutmaster to save the day.
So I meandered back to my tent, grabbed my spatula, put it in my pocket
and made my way back to the cooking area.
And when I got there, to my surprise, the boys had figured out how they were
going to flip those pancakes.
They took a pie tin, cut it up into about a maybe a quarter of a pie tin,
folded around a few times and they made themselves a spatula,
And that thing worked dandy.
Now I didn't get a chance to save the day, which was a good thing.
It just goes to show that had I stepped in and saved the day
with my awesome spatula, the kids wouldn't have had the opportunity
to innovate and use the resources that they have.
It taught me a big lesson that day: that as a Scoutmaster,
I need to sit back and do a little more watching and a lot less doing.
Thanks for listening,
Shane. thanks so much for taking the time to do that.
I think that's a great story and a very practical example.
It's amazing what boys can do once we kind of get out of the way
and let them figure it out.
So in this week's podcast we've got answers to some of your email questions,
But before that, Scoutmastership, in seven minutes or less,
we're going to start a series on the four steps to advancement,
And I think that should fill the podcast nicely.
So let's get started.
Scoutmastership in seven minutes or less.
Well, there are four steps to scout advancement
And these are described in the Scoutmasters Handbook,
And it's starting on page 124, if you want to check.
And before we examine these four steps,
which we're going to do in a series over the next several podcasts,
it's important that we contextualize advancement
within all the aims and methods of scouting.
Let's go to the guide to advancement 2011 for a second,
because there's a good statement there.
It said: advancement is simply a means to an end,
not an end in itself.
It is one of several methods designed to help unit leadership
carry out the aims and mission of the Boy Scouts of America.
This is from Baden Powell's AIDS to Scoutmastership.
And you know what,
When you go back to the founder here, the guy who originated the idea,
no one does a better job of describing the spirit of advancement
in scouting than the man who developed it in the first place.
He said this: the badges, or, you know,
the awards that we give out are not intended to signify
that a scout is master in the craft he has tested in.
If once we make scouting into a formal scheme
of serious instruction in efficiency,
we miss the whole point and value of scout training.
We want to get all of our boys along
through cheery self-development from within,
not through the imposition of formal instruction from without.
The object of the badge system in scouting-
now you know this was written back in the 1920s,
so let's update the term badge system to advancement.
The object of advancement in scouting is also to give the scoutmaster
an instrument by which he can stimulate keenness
on the part of every and any boy
to take up hobbies that can be helpful
in forming his character or developing his skill.
It is for this reason the reason is:
this is a tool that can be used by scoutmasters
to stimulate interest and keenness
on the part of every and any boy.
That's the reason we have this system.
So the reason that for that reason,
the standard of proficiency
or the standard of performance
is purposefully left undefined.
Our standard for advancement
is not the attainment of a certain level
of quality of knowledge or skill,
but the amount of effort
the boy has put into acquiring such knowledge or skill.
If he is a trier, no matter how clumsy
his examiner can accord him his badge,
and this generally inspires the boy to go on
and to try till he wins further badges
and becomes even more capable.
Some are inclined to insist that their scout
should be first rate before they can get a badge.
That is very right in theory.
You do get a few boys pretty proficient in this way.
But our object is to get all the boys interested
At the same time. we do not recommend the other extreme,
namely that of almost giving away the badges
on very slight knowledge of the subjects.
It is a matter where examiners
should use their sense and discretion,
keeping the main aim in view.
We're going to mention that little sentence there
many, many times in this series.
Keeping the main aim in view.
Our aim is to make boys into smiling,
sensible, self-effacing, hardworking people
instead of showy, self-indulgent people.
Thus the success of the badge system
depends very largely on the scout master himself
and his individual handling of it.
And once again that's Baden Powell in his book
Aids to Scout Mastership.
I was given that on a mimeograph sheet
25 or so years ago during scout master training,
and there is nothing I have ever read or was taught
that has had more effect on the way I approached scouting
than the ideas on that one mimeograph sheet
And those ideas were Baden Powell kind of laying out
what he intended in instituting this advancement system.
Now the things that Baden Powell had to say then
are also echoed in the present edition of the
Scout Masters Handbook.
And just to run that down, there's three or four things.
A boy can work on the requirements at his own speed.
Boys should not be pressured to advance or given deadlines,
And even the decision to advance at all
lies with each boy.
Nothing inspires boys to advance more than a lively troop program.
If we take care of the program
and we make sure that it's lively and engaging,
advancement is going to be the inevitable outcome.
Baden Powell said something else that I think is important
to help us contextualize advancement
within all the aims and methods of scouting.
He said this advancement is like a suntan,
something you get naturally while you're having fun in the outdoors.
So scout advancement is not a goal for us. really
It's an indicator.
Our aim is not that scouts attain a certain level of skill
or expertise, just like Baden Powell said,
but that they have fun in the outdoors
doing the things that the scouts do.
When that happens they gain skills and they have fun,
And in the course of camping trips.
scouts work with their hands and understand
and adapt to their environment.
They build fires and cook food and explore and talk
and work together.
They do all manner of things. they consider fun
with very little prompting.
Fun's important and fun is vital,
but sometimes within the context of advancement,
fun has a bad reputation.
Fun is sometimes seen as a waste of time
or a distraction from more serious work
like quote-unquote, doing requirements,
Lively, program scouts doing the thing that scouts do
and having a lot of fun. they're going to advance.
It's just a natural outcome.
The last thing I'll say in contextualizing
the whole idea of advancement
is that it's important to understand
advancement in scouting is a unique system of learning.
It's not academic in its approach,
It's not competitive,
It's not an end in itself.
And a key aspect of applying the program
is understanding that we can't import
the practices of the academic world
into the scout world
and just apply those to advancement.
And we're going to expand on that
as we talk about the four steps
in advancement in scouting.
Now, these four steps are:
a scout learns,
a scout is tested,
a scout is reviewed
and a scout is recognized.
In future podcasts we're going to examine
these four steps without trying
to overcomplicate or confuse things.
There are misconceptions that arise
from time to time and become common practice
that can derail scout advancement
from the simple, direct and enjoyable work
that it was intended to be.
Next time we're going to talk
about that first step in advancement:
a scout learns
DRIVE.
E-mail- that is folks,
And here's an answer to one of your emails
E-mail.
I receive this e-mail from somebody who asked me
if I would withhold their name,
name and location details. but this is a volunteer with a scout troop and he says
we have a new scout who joined just a few weeks ago whose family is vegan and that
means no animal product of any kind. The boy, who's never really cooked his own
meals and his mother is slightly- is pretty concerned about how what he is
going to eat. on campouts We have and will continue and accommodate diet
restrictions like nut allergies and things like that. One other scout in our
troop just chooses not to eat red meat and we've also had folks who
require gluten-free. It may seem like an open-ended question. I don't really know
where to draw the line, accommodating all these different dietary needs, but I've
been listening to your podcast and blog for several months now. Your opinion
perspective always seemed to give me an aha moment, so thanks for the time. Well,
thank you for being in touch and I'm glad you're enjoying the podcast and
the blog. The aha moment on this one is asking the patrol leader and the youth
leadership how they plan on accommodating these dietary restrictions.
That's where I would begin. If they don't really know what to do, at that point
we can ask some more questions, see if they can get the idea They can talk
to the scout and they can talk to the scout's parents and they can begin to
craft a solution With a new scout. mom isn't really going to understand how
things work, but she'll catch on as time goes by and you'll be helping her
understand these things. Let the scouts sort this one out. They may have much
better ideas than you or mom or even me. I have two scouts right now who are
gluten-free and I have one scout who is Muslim and has some religious based
dietary restrictions. Now thus far it's not really been a big deal for their
patrols. I honestly don't know what they do. I think the whole patrol with
the gluten-free boys goes gluten-free sometimes and sometimes they just get
alternatives for that scout. but they all figure it out eventually. Now my gluten
free scouts. their mom is constantly concerned about this and just about
insisted that they bring their own food when they first joined the troop. but
she got over it and she saw the patrol figured this out on their own. Now
it goes without saying they don't do this perfectly and sometimes they need
a little bit of assistance and some reminders. They can work it out. On our
trips to Canada and Switzerland, the gluten-free scouts were still part of
the meal plan and we just bought. alternatives were needed and things
were fine. The other thing I can offer is that if people complain about
making these kind of dietary accommodations, I would ask them if
they'd complain if you made accommodations for a scout who, because
of religious belief, had dietary restrictions, like our Muslim scout, or if
they would complain because the scout was in a wheelchair or somehow
differently abled and you had to make accommodations so that they could
participate, and participate comfortably and be included in things. A vegan diet
may not be a choice, but it's not the boys choice, it's his parents choice and
he really can't do anything about that. so making these dietary accommodations-
sometimes their health reasons, sometimes their choice reasons, sometimes
their religious reasons. when we first had to do this years and years ago,
when you know, we first were confronted with the allergies and everything like
that, I thought it was kind of irritating. but when I put it in the hands of the
youth leadership and I described what needed to happen, they seem to take it
on in in stride and they have been able to work things out as time goes by, so
that hopefully that supplies an aha moment for you. Glenn is in St
Peter's, Missouri, with Troop 857 and he emailed this question in. he said you
recently posted regarding advancement to first class and there was a post on the
blog last week about advancement to first class in the first year- that first
class emphasis. do you have advice or a good system for handbook sign-offs? we
tend to get boys that after a few outings or more, shove a handbook in
front of us and ask if they are ready for anything to be signed off. of course
we turn it around and ask them to tell us what they've completed, but it
usually takes some discussion and questioning to confirm which outings
they attended and which requirements they satisfied. we've been working to get
the senior patrol leader and patrol leaders more involved in signing off
requirements for ranks up to first class. do you have any magical words of
wisdom? well, Glenn, sometimes I have a ha moments and sometimes I have magical
words of wisdom. so welcome to magical words of wisdom. so far as your
question, Glenn, I gotta tell you there's really no system. there's no easy
procedural fix. scouts are scouts of, boys, are boys and they're all over the map so
far as this is concerned. some are of top on top of things and they, as you know,
within minutes of completing a requirement they find somebody to sign
it, and some just don't even think about it. the best thing I can tell you is
to respond whenever they're ready. I used to kind of worry about this, but
I learned I have very little to do with scouts advancing. it's their thing.
they do it, however, and they do it however they please and they do it when
they get around to it. our responsibility is really focused on creating
opportunities, and that does include making opportunities for requirements
to get signed off and letting them know. that that's, you know, something
that could be done anytime. it's really not our responsibility to make them
advance or otherwise, coerce them or require them to advance or to own
advancement. it begins and ends with the individual scout. he owns his own
advancement. he gets to do it at the pace that he wants to, and we can
certainly encourage, but we don't want to do too much beyond that now. when we
adopt this approach, scouts are going to understand sooner or later that it's
all on them and then, if they really get themselves interested in advancing,
they fly in ahead and we can't stop them. if we have some kind of set,
program or schedule or something like that, they'll be waiting for us to make
them do something and they'll wait every single time and we'll end up
dragging them along. 98% of the requirements to first class can be
signed off by patrol leaders and above. the way to make this happen is for
adults just to stop doing it, except maybe an extraordinary circumstances
where a patrol leader isn't available to sign off a requirement. and I
really encourage you: if your youth leaders aren't signing off
requirements, sit down with them, describe how it works and let them
have a go. I think it's very important for them to be able to do that up
to first class, and really the only qualification they need to be able
to sign the requirement off is it be one that they have themselves
completed. it works for us. we've got a troop of 3035 boys with
regular rank advancement, regular merit badges coming in, and you
know those two or three Eagles. every year that happened. so I
really encourage you to take a look at that now. hopefully that
will pass for magical words of wisdom. thank you so much for being
touched, Glenn. I hope that helps. you can get in touch too. we'll
answer your email questions right here on the podcast, as well as
responding to them on the internet, and I'm going to tell
you how to get in touch in just a moment.
well, thanks for listening. here's how you can keep in touch. read
the scout master blog at scoutmastercgcom and, while you're
there, you can subscribe to receive updates to the blog by email.
you can subscribe to the scout master podcast on itunes and
when you do, would you take a moment, leave a comment or
review a rating? that's always appreciated. you can also access
the podcast on any mobile device through Stitcher smart radio,
and you can get details about how to do that at stitchercom.
you can call in and record a shout out to be included in a
future edition of the scout master podcast. go to scoutmastercgcom
and follow the shout out link and you can experience the
wonders of scoutmastercgcom through the vast panorama of
social media outlets. you can follow us at scoutmaster
blog on facebook, tweet scoutmastercg on twitter and,
for admittance to the exclusive scout master cg circle,
search for scout master cg on google plus. and if all of that
fails, if you're not into social media, well you know what? you
can: email me, clark green, with your comments and questions.
and, uh, you can get in touch with me at scoutmastercg at
Verizonnet. the scout master blog and the scout master
podcast are not official publications of the Boy Scouts of America,
nor are they endorsed or sponsored by the Boy Scouts of America.
hey, it's just me, that's right, talking into a microphone, trying to
lend a hand to scout leaders and have some fun along the way.
and before we leave you, let's hear from our founder, sir robert
baton Powell. sir robert, good luck to you and good
camping, why? thank you, sir, until next time
you.